yeah and I think I think you see that's  right that you the only that you've got  to distinguish between somebody who  somebody may feel that their view is  inherently better than that of somebody  else's because it's motivated by  religious faith but the point is within  the system young yep it's not it's not  better okay no so that's why these  principles about equal voice is so  important because in a way you can't  stop people thinking whatever they think  or what you can say is you may think  that but actually here are the rules and  you abide by them as well and i think  that's that's why it's so important that  you know that in a sense the essential  covenant or contract or even compromise  that there is between the secular and  the religious is to say you know  religious people of faith are entitled  to speak and have their opinion and have  it motivated by faith but they still  abide by the rules